[Musique]
Gabriel la neige et le verglace ont
attendu dans les ivelines cette nuit
comment le département se prépare-t-il
et bien Mathilde la préfecture des
ivelines a enclenché la vigilance orange
neige Vergl depuis hier soir 22h et
jusque demain 10h alors 20 sleuses et
des neigeuses seront déployés dans la
soirée des axes valallonnais comme la N
118 pourrai être amené à fermer on fait
un point sur la site sittion avec
Richard de le piierre en charge des
transports et des mobilités dans les
ivelines on est évidemment parfaitement
préparé équipé pour traiter nos voiries
en neiger on est toujours plus inquiet
pour le verglas parce que c'est beaucoup
plus dangereux donc là on n pas de pas
de sujet on sait que la neige va arriver
on ne sait pas en quelle quantité elle
va tomber les alertes météo sont pas
fait pour qu'on ne s'en serve pas donc
tous ceux qui n'ont pas besoin de
prendre leur voiture demain sont
évidemment inviter à ne pas la prendre
les routes sont quand même compliquées à
circuler même si les voies sont traitées
il y aura de la neige il y aura sans
doute de la neige en quantité important
alors si vous devez quand même vous
déplacer privilégie les transports en
commun et sachez que les RER A et B
circuleront à blanc toute la nuit pour
éviter le gel sur le réseau ferré et
pour rester informé sur les opérations
en cours l'agglomération de SaintQuentin
en Yveline a mis en place le service
hivernal alerte SMS et surtout soyez
prudent dans vos déplacements en ce
début d'année 2024 des nouvelles
communes intègrent le dispositif
quartier prioritaire de la ville oui et
de nouveau quartiers intègreent ce
dispositif les acaticia aquanière et
larve aux clés sous-bois de leur côté
les petits prês à héencour et vieux pays
à Sartrouville n'en font plus partie
instauré en 2015 ce dispositif vise à
réduire les écarts de développement de
certaines villes il améliore l'accès à
l'emploi la culture la réussite scolaire
en 2023 dans les ivelin 4 millions
d'euros avaient été investis pour
rénover des infrastructures et plus de
700 jeunes avaient été accompagné retard
et suppression voilà le quotidien des
voyageurs qui empruntent le tramé T13
oui et depuis presque 2 semaines c'est
comme ça la circulation du T13 est
perturbée et ce au moins jusqu'à fin
février de 21h à minuit tout le long de
la ligne c'est-à-dire de Saint-Germain
en lait à saint-sy pour le weekend le
trafic reste habituel c'est d règlements
ils sont dus à des travaux de
prolongement des chemins de fer
l'objectif relié her à la ville de Saint
Germain en lait en passant par poissie
des bus de substitution sont mis en
place en revanche vous l'imaginez
Mathilde la vigilance orange neigevergl
risque d'ajouter des dérèglements ces
prochaines heures un mot de sport à
présent Gabriel le Stade Français va
bientôt s'installer dans lesivvelg oui
le camp des Loges de Saint-Germain enlè
va passer du bleu au rose et pour cause
le club de rugby parisien devrait s'y
installer le site était libre depuis le
départ du PSG à poissie c'est le club
parisien actuellement 3 du Top 14 qui va
prendre possession des lieux d'après nos
confrères du Parisien les travaux
devraient bientôt commencer sur le site
l'installation est prévue cet été pour
ce que l'on surnomme les soldas roses on
poursuit avec du sport une mauvaise
nouvelle en tennis oui Mathilde il n'y a
plus d'ivelinois dans le tableau final
de l'Open d'Australie Caroline Garcia
originaire de Saint-Germain en lait a
été éliminée au 2uxè tour du tournoi du
grand schlem une défaite en 27 face à la
Polonaise Magdalena frche 64 76 grosse
déception pour la française 19e au
classement WTA qui s'incline contre la
69e joueuse mondiale et on termine avec
une actu cinéma Gabriel oui alors
aujourd'hui est sorti dans les salles le
film comme un prince parmi les acteurs
Ahmed Sila ou encore Jonathan Cohen le
film met en scène un boxeur qui rêve de
devenir champion olympique avant de se
blesser au cours d'une bagarre il va
alors devoir effectuer plusieurs heures
de travaux d'intérêt général et si je
vous en parle mail c'est qu'une partie
des scènes du film on été tourné dans
les iines plus précisément au Mureau on
regarde un extrait de la bande annonce
on est très attendu sur ces jeux
olympies les gars j'attends de vous un
comportement
irréprochableo Mo j'ai
rien c'est pas moi qui fait c'est mon
pote qui fait c'est lui qui avait le
fusil la gosse je vous jure je l'ai pas
touché parle
la c'est bagarre les tiges c'est pas les
vacances tman il va être avec nous
pendant quelques mois là au jardin il a
joué au con et il a perdu voilà bah nous
on a rien fait on est la gros alors
parmi les lieux reconnaissables dans le
film Le club de boxe du BAM l'héritage
ou encore le gymnase Pierre de Coubertin
tourné au Mureau était une volonté du
réalisateur qui a grandi dans la commune
le film il s'inscrit dans la volonté de
la Ville d'accueillir davantage de
tournages c'est un film que j'irais bien
voir au cinéma et ben vous pouvez y
aller dès ce soir
merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous avez une
actualité une image ou une information
qui vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
7 news